as I've said at this initial stage and
this an estate all of these graphs you
don't need addition or subtraction
orders to do these okay
however the whole point is to try and
practice a skill so actually you can
understand better what is going on
so example hopefully we know by
factorizing right that I could just
write this as this sir I it's a parabola
I know exactly where the roots are going
to go I know it's concave up or concave
down in order or not so I could make
that argument but what I'm trying to do
is trying to understand is through a
different lens this will become even
more important we look at reciprocals so
you can see on the ungrate graphs I've
broken it up onto its components
so really I'm dealing with these two
guys okay
now watch as I approach with the same
process because it's some ways right for
a lot of us like coming up with the
graph this is magic it's been checked by
which I mean like why is it could you
explain to like a six year kyu get that
shape and you're just like well that's
just because it's the shape you get like
it's so part of the way you think down
okay now to your credit you probably
could let you get out a little bit you
can play why routes are reached and so
on but I can approach it a completely
different way so let's do it by addition
importance firstly important points what
do you reckon is the most important
point Vanya
I probably say the origin because look
at that point both graphs are equal to
zero so when I add them together
once I get a zero
exactly the same way just sort of moving
over a little bit right there is going
to be a point when this positive and
this negative are exactly equal to each
other and therefore will cancel right so
I know I've seen this before
I guess it'll be somewhere like there
okay so I'm gonna pop that value is it
and I happen to know the actual value is
equal to 2 okay and by the way you can
do that you very clear right you want
this and this to be equal right or this
appears to be opposite so 2 squared
negative 4 BAM you there
so now I know I hear that yeah now let
me think about this let's see the easy
part first
over on the left overall the left I'm
gonna think about it from left to right
so I can use by increasing and
decreasing language right for my
component functions from left to right
what's why because they get 2x is it
decreasing your dignity it's decreasing
what about X square also decreasing
they're both decreases so when you put
together two things that are decreasing
they will both decrease even faster does
that make sense they're both going down
on the right hand side this is a bit
trickier right have a look at this
little spot here between here right what
is increasing at what is decreasing now
that question is which one is more
important which one is increasing or
decreasing more than the other one like
a tug-of-war who's pulling harder
okay no now if we look at this very
carefully and slowly it's the whole
point of picking up different way right
at the beginning the straight line is
pulling harder right the reason you can
do that is because right there at that
point the parabola is not pulling it off
the Grady would be zero right and then
it lifts off quite quickly and as you
can see for that brief moment this guy
down here that pulley the decreasing is
decreasing harder so that's why it comes
down right but then eventually the
parameter wakes up and he says well okay
I'm going to stop pulling and he quickly
outpaces right so that's why it
decreases first Shore down but then it
increases again as this fell I suck the
pool hot does that make sense now think
for a second what's the gradient I'm not
gonna talk in actual numbers what's the
greatest line it's negative two but so
there's an exact point you can find it
where the gradient of this parabola is
the opposite to and that's the
break-even point right when this guy is
pulling at two and this one is pulling
at negative two they will cancel and
recall that a stationary point right
because yes they have been bullied they
are pointing in exactly opposite
directions at exactly the same amount
right because their gradients are
opposites to each other does that make
sense so if they point in opposite
direction it's exactly the same amount
they're not moving anywhere and
stationary does that make sense which of
course we know is it going to be exactly
halfway between the briefs because
parameters are symmetrical does that
make sense you see how I logic that out
in a completely different way from
saying well a parabola has a vertex and
it's supposed to be there okay
I'm trying to think about how the graphs
are behaving together and lastly over
here on the right well this guy is well
actually taken over has it he's
increasing he's decreasing but he's
never gonna catch up because he's always
pulling the same rate okay so therefore
that's how you get this shape that's
gonna increase forever and we already
know what's happening
like so okay does it make sense
so the probably you'll always expect to
you but we thought about it we refers to
a very different way